you
[Music]
it's a beautiful day for this
neighborhood a beautiful day for a
neighbor won't you be mine could you be
mine
it's a neighborly day in this beauty
would a neighborly day for this beauty
could you be mine
won't you be mine I have always wanted
to have a neighbor just like you I've
always wanted to live in neighbourhood
with you so let's make since we're
together we might as well say would you
be mine would you be mine won't you be
my neighbor
won't you be won't you please please
won't you be my subscriber what is it
with you it's distracting what I'm
trying to do my work do I come into your
place and screw with your sound no
you're a nice guy you're a nice guy
answer me it's distracting when I'm
trying to sing a song answer me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right let me with you that sound is
of course the sound of the weekend I
know we really know so it's not always
the sound of the weekend but this is a
Thursday live stream producing with me
in video studio as always it's Jarrod
who is not gay follow him on the Twitter
at not gay Jarrod me a test credits
medical applications draw your own
conclusions were good I'm good
big show big shell big show coming up
this evening we had to by the way for
those who are disappointed bo Derek
quickly moved to next week because Tim
Kennedy is on tonight because he's been
all over the news
so that was kind of necessary and we
were able to get him in an Mackel and he
talking about the new Gosnell book she
has coming out of course in relation to
the woman's life March and your tweets
later on in the program so be sure to
have those live tweets ready we'll be
happy to read them big big story right
now big story yes doomsday have you guys
heard about this I have doomsday this is
when it's a slow news cycle you have
stories that actually include the word
doomsday that's that's how you know it's
slow CBS News they ran a live stream
with scientists I'm doing a lot of air
quotes Hillary I don't like how this is
beginning who've decided to now move the
Doomsday Clock up from 3 minutes to
midnight to two and a half minutes to
now nice quote world leaders have failed
to come to grips with humanity's most
pressing X pressing existential threats
Perez what am i John Malkovich the most
pressing existential threats nuclear
weapons and climate change disturbing
comment nothing for John Malkovich Oh
Cal broker disturbing comments about the
use and proliferation of nuclear weapons
made by Donald Trump as well as the
expressed disbelief in the overwhelming
scientific consensus on climate change
by both Trump and several of his cabinet
appointees effected the Board's decision
as did the emergence of strident
nationalism worldwide okay so Donald
Trump was of course specifically
mentioned and CBS took this incredible
they took this what you're reading very
seriously as displayed by this man at
CBS who appears to be soiling him to go
that Doomsday Clock moved forward of 30
seconds and now stands at two and a half
minutes before midnight that's the
closest to midnight or the
of the world as it's been in 64 years it
is a metaphor but we are literally
minutes away from a nuclear exchange to
someone press a button it's an analogy
but literally it's not although that guy
pooped himself there's a mirrors face he
had kind of that Garry Shandling oh
what's this
that's managed this story's this fixed
that's the [ __ ] phone I think it is
hello commissioner [ __ ]
yes sir uh-huh sir right away sir
understood sir
[Music]
you gave a lot of work to yourself with
the sensor button on that one says
catchy though we have just been informed
by Commissioner Bullock that this story
is in fact 100% unadulterated [ __ ]
this is not science first off let me
clarify this a live stream of scientists
complaining about nationalism and tying
that into a political that's not what
science is that's not what good science
makes and I know people will say you're
you're dealing no we're not dealing in
junk science okay a live stream where
you tie a nuclear holocaust directly to
Donald Trump directly to climate change
directly to polar bears dying these are
the same people who've made several
other predictions well isn't it good
that we have these examples if we didn't
you might think we're lying to you know
if you want that Helen over to CPS
predictions when Donald truck will
become president they said the stock
market would crash that was a concrete
prediction they made Dow Jones for the
first time hit 20,000 yesterday no
another prediction they said mosques
would be a thing of the past
as soon as Donald Trump was elected that
has not happened they also the same-sex
marriage would be overturned was another
prediction if they made sorryi
same-sex marriage would be overturned
according to their predictions that has
not happened as a matter of fact Donald
Trump doesn't really care about to rump
Rangers getting hitched it doesn't seem
to be at the top of his radar right now
the science Marsh that's of course why
this live stream occurred the science
March which implies what that all
Republicans conservatives are against
science except these are the same people
explaining to you that there are 52
genders this is the same political wing
that predicted the ice caps would melt
entirely by 2013 on gone and then when
they realize that wasn't the case they
shift the prediction to 2016 and now we
haven't heard from the guy by the way
the Florida Keys are still lovely they
still are lovely yeah someone tweeted me
today why don't you go to Florida and
see all the cities that are dying you
know I actually have relatives in
Florida I visit them every year and they
live on the coast it's it's quite lovely
and finally these are the same people
who made the prediction that the polar
bears would die off when they're
actually more right now arguably than
ever in recorded history the only debate
is whether they've in fact doubled or
tripled or maybe added about 50% but
there are far more polar bears now than
there were when Al Gore did his film so
when these people give you these
doomsday predictions on a live stream we
can tell
you beyond any shadow of a doubt that
this is unequivocally boy
[Music]
let it go in case we didn't drive that
point home that phone is heavy I wanted
to make sure we didn't we didn't put a
hole through the [ __ ] phone it's
carrying a lot of weight uh-huh
something I'd like to get into macro I
think matters is is we were at the March
and some people have asked us you know
what is it that these people were
marching about and every now and then
people ask me questions and I really
don't have the answer to them and so it
makes me want to ask that question and
it is one of the questions where if I
got an answer with new evidence with new
information that I don't currently have
I'd be more than open to changing my
opinion so if there's someone out there
who's a feminist or a black lives matter
activist who's actually willing to come
on the program and set me straight I
would really I would welcome you if you
look to our interviews with with Sally
cone with Christopher Titus with Zack
Ford with Harrison green but we've had
plenty of left us on the show we really
do try and keep it respectful even if I
disagree with you I would like to know
what is it when we're talking about
equality these marches when we asked
they had no idea but what is equality I
want to know when people say we're
fighting for equal rights today what
does that mean feminists what are you
talking about I understand at one point
in this country what we want the right
to vote good got it we want the right to
receive equal pay you should for the
same job we want the right to go out and
purchase the same goods or services that
men do or that white people do or that
non trans people do understood but in
2017 when you go out and you March and
the media refers to this as the biggest
modern civil rights march of all time it
begs the question okay
what's civil rights what are we talking
about when we're talking about equality
now I know when I talk about equality
I'm talking about equal opportunity I'm
talking about constitutional equality
life liberty pursuit of happiness and
maybe I'm off but I don't see it today I
mean I can see how people would have
argued you know before the gay marriage
thing I don't really think that marriage
is a fundamental human right we can get
into that I guess you know [ __ ]
being able to take a dump on the neutral
bathroom on a plane that's important
stuff that's important I understand but
beyond that you have a bigger issue
these are the bigger issues when you
have to
in people getting together and you've
Ashley Judd and Madonna and whoever it
is and they are demanding equal rights
to the point of marching and civil
unrest and throwing trash cans through
windows because Donald Trump is
president I don't agree with him on
everything but this is a sincere
question if someone can give me an
answer what are the equal rights in 2017
afforded to a white straight male that
are that is not afforded to a female to
a person of color you can't say African
American that switched fast to a person
tweet made s Crowder I would love to
hear that speaking of which
HuffPo proudly reported yesterday when a
group of women confronted a New Jersey
politician I believe he was the County
freeholder over a joke here was his joke
he tweeted it out tweeted he put on
Facebook sorry he said something along
the lines of you know the women's March
good for you I want to know will the
woman being home in time to cook dinner
pretty benign pretty benign you would
think naive of that clever no it's not
that clever and so as you can see from
these images I think we will bring up
there's a video somewhere online I
believe women actually lined up at the
next public meeting to protest him their
goal is knock the door and they
certainly asked him to apologize and he
did he did apologize he said it wasn't
meant to offend anybody and all the
strong woman in my life who saw it took
it for what it was a joke and it wasn't
enough that's a lot of women someone
definitely miss dinner no no they still
walked out on him when he was explaining
this and I just I think we've gone
beyond the bend here where it should a
politician tweet that from a political
account maybe not but has this really
wounded you to the point that you have
lost all trust in your public servants
that a guy tweeted a joke about
sandwiches and by the way it's not that
much of a joke because we know that
feminists can't cook so of all the
people to be upset by the yeah I had
heard that you made a comment regarding
the women's March last week where Ashley
Judd made a speech that she was probably
on her menstrual cycle did I made a joke
about that I don't I don't recall making
that yeah I think you did did I
you know what I'm looking I don't think
I don't think I did I think you actually
got this I think this happened she spent
a lot of time on the period thing which
makes me think she's absolutely barren
let's go to clip through you know upon
reflection I think I did say that
sentence yeah
so are you going to apologize for that I
have no intention of apologizing no oh I
think that's really mean okay well thank
you we need to get better security in
here do it's interesting to when we talk
about equal rights that women have
seemingly gotten on board with pushing
the black lives matter agenda where when
you really understand about Margaret
Sanger and what she thought about yeah
yeah why didn't she once fat shame a
woman by saying her blood type was
pudding I don't I I don't I don't think
I said that I don't believe so
actually I'm looking through because the
archives here and I found this this is a
morbidly obese woman okay for people who
are not who are listening to rationally
look at the picture I mean her blood
type is pudding you know what I did I
did say that so you're gonna apologize
fat right no no I'm not yeah okay thank
you if we want to talk about systemic
discrimination I think it's a
conversation we can have if you want to
get to the women's suffrage movement you
want to get to the suffragettes
suffragettes which are actually
different by the way Karen strong has
talked about that has talked about women
getting the right to vote without having
bucket duty without having the draft if
we want to discuss them yes mm-hmm
it's intrude and you once made a joke
about feminists being raped
oh well that act that actually does
sound like something I might have done
at one point I don't know if I don't but
I don't think it's what she thinks it is
I did find this one example I don't know
if this is what she's talking about
oh yes the feminists raped in a forced
joke well that the context of that was
because Lena Dunham and everyone's
coming out with fake rape stories and
they were always saying that there was
no evidence and so it wasn't really a
joke about feminists it was a joke about
feminists just simply accusing rape when
they snow
and so I I did make that joke yeah well
you understand and it's still offending
you know very much I can I can see yes
are you planning to apologize um well
I'm sure you probably saw this one
coming no yes that's that's that's just
yeah listen okay I understand you're
gonna have to bleep that Jared for our
international audience that can present
a problem problematic look it looks like
it's gonna be tough to get a word in
edgewise here we have a line up out the
door it's almost like the new it's like
there's a new Star Wars film I don't
know how this happened and apparently we
have to let somebody go in security
we'll be back to talk about equality and
talk more about Donald Trump after this
I have to go talk to security
[Music]
Timmy wasn't feeling well so he came in
to the doctor for a checkup
Oh Timmy just the doctor suspected
you're a whiny [ __ ] the good news for
you is there's a prescription mug Club
clinically proven to reduce whiny
factory by 49 percent for only 99
dollars annually 69 dollars for students
veterans or active military bladder with
chrono calm slash mug Club four out of
five doctors agree if you're a whiny
food mug clubs for you
[Music]
oh all right glad to be back we have Tim
Kennedy coming up after the break then
later and McElhinney and your tweets by
the way still going on right now
Shia LaBeouf's he will not divide us yes
live stream that still happen in case
you know still going on he was arrested
we wrote about this I think he's out of
the clink now he should be good we'll
check in on that a little bit later
because um well get some press now
people want to see that okay let's get
to this point here this we're going
macro point kind of like equality have
you noticed right now that the media and
and Paul Krugman in New York Times are
all saying you know what no it's
important you need to call Donald Trump
on his lies you need to stop being
afraid to stand up to Donald Trump you
been hearing this right a lot over when
you'd said it yeah Keith Olbermann
that's right Keith Olbermann well mr.
mink you know mr. Maybellene himself
Keith Olbermann I I don't know if what
parallel universe are they living in
where nobody's speaking out against
Donald Trump in the media so you need to
be brave you need to be willingness what
the other day I was an entire gender'
that was supposed to be speaking yeah it
was an entire ginger
according to Aziz Ansari good point an
entire gender' was speaking out against
Donald Trump and so this is kind of like
in the in the in the entertainment
industry the idea of a journalist to
will forgo the money to maintain their
honesty and integrity and going after
the story those kinds of journalists
they only exist in film in real life
you've got the Dan Rather is you've got
the Brian Williams you've got the Keith
Olbermann's here's here is something on
the other side of the coin let me
present this to you
not only do they stand up to Donald
Trump they completely bully anyone and
everyone who even mildly supports him it
matter--it view look when it's a slow
news day it is nothing but an T Trump
says it I listen I understand this you
should send up to Donald Trump if he
lies you should stand up to Sean Spicer
is incorrect if he cites a number that's
inaccurate we do you can all have even
some fun some fun aesthetics and his
expense I don't know if I just had a
stroke with that word twister he did how
much wood would a woodchuck chuck if a
woodchuck could chuck suck at hosting a
show that was um that's fine but then if
you look at the media the ones who are
patting themselves on the back
incessant ly for standing up and you
look at the trivial crap after which
they attack the Trump's I I just it's
one of those things where I don't know
if they're doing it to try and create a
narrative it's that's false or that
they're delusional what do you think is
is more likely as a possibility I think
they're probably just addicted to the
addicted yes they're addicted to the
hatred just hook it to my veins BuzzFeed
so let's grab a few examples to policy
fine trade fine even taxes maybe you
disagree fine you can do that but
Samantha be for example these are the
brave journalist Samantha P took it upon
herself to go on an entire rant about
Donald Trump's inauguration in a wait
for it in a very [ __ ] snide unfunny
way it wasn't I know you'll say you'd
yes I do that as well but I don't act as
though I'm brave for standing now of
course it is more brave to do what we do
from our side of the aisle being younger
being conservative on YouTube or
Facebook or Twitter as you see by the
bannings but there's nothing brave about
someone like Samantha be standing up to
Trump by mocking you just watch this
clip and see if you understand where I'm
coming from did I mention the concert
was officially called the make America
great again exclamation point welcome
celebration and what makes America great
apparently the total absence of any
women whatsoever
Trump's concert was like his cabinet
mail overwhelmingly white and devoid of
ælis talent
[Laughter]
again this is standing people who are
terrified into silence don't simply mock
someone like the popular girl at high
school for not having talented artists
you know why Donald Trump couldn't get
big name artists because they were
intimidated into silence it would be
braver for them to show up and perform
because then we know that they'd be
risking work in the entertainment
industry because you all follow lockstep
with each other
so again let's let's spin to anyone on
this theme of journalists beings cuz
they need to start standing up okay well
what about Seth Meyers who took it upon
himself to mock Donald Trump for
watching too much television yeah this
is what happens in a slow news cycle
Seth Meyers standing up to Donald Trump
no longer be
afraid by mocking his TV watching habits
exactly been a reassuring start for the
Trump administration and some people
close to Trump seem very eager to give
reporters damning details about where he
gets his information from expressing
concern in particular that he watches
too much TV Politico reported this week
that quote one person who frequently
talks to Trump said aides have to push
back privately against his worst
impulses in the White House and have to
control information that may infuriate
him he gets bored and likes to watch TV
so it is important to minimize that hey
I hear you I'm dealing with the same
issue with my son he's nine months old
and we're trying to observe a no screens
rule but sometimes he gets cranky and
the only thing that works his Dora the
Explorer so being there that's kind of
funny sure but these are the same people
who want you to believe that they're
risking jail time by speaking out
against an authoritarian figure I'll
continue to present my case BuzzFeed had
an article up let's bring this up where
they were insisting that Mel Gibson
who's now being nominated for an Oscar
is the definitive Oscar nominee for
Trump's America so let's be clear now
these people want to act as though they
need to be brave they're standing up
there doing the right thing here they're
saying because Mel Gibson at one time
went to crazy drunken anti-semitic
tirades to be fair could very well still
be an anti-semite probably you can take
the boy out of the anti-semitism but you
can't take the Jew hate out of the boy
so I don't know but the point is because
Mel Gibson mate let's even give them
that maybe a current drunken anti-semite
and he was nominated for something that
has nothing to do with his political
worldview but being a fantastic
filmmaker because Mel Gibson is a
fantastic filmmaker warranting
recognition Donald Trump racism I see I
could see where they made the connection
yeah the dots are there it just takes a
little but again I do appreciate the
backbone same thing BuzzFeed also took
time to point out that searching for
bigoted or racist on Twitter brings up
real Donald Trump by the way these
people want you to be on the lookout for
fake news yes you need not concern
yourself with news coming from other
political points of view this is
breaking and it's important because
BuzzFeed ben ben smith does act as
though they are
newsmakers' they are real news reporters
this is I know you're probably laughing
right congratulations you're a rational
person you probably laughing when
someone puts the words BuzzFeed and news
in the same sentence but they fancy
themselves that way and they're the ones
who actually written articles saying
it's time to stand up against Trump
right let's talk about Twitter searches
and algorithms and copy/paste at the
Donald Trump and pat ourselves in the
back
what else we have uh well there's
there's so much I mean we can go down
and CNN and BuzzFeed the disaster but
here's something that they even it goes
all the way down the line not only
making fun of Donald Trump's children I
wasn't that I outraged by it but again
we're talking about this pseudo bravery
they even went into the files to pull up
for a charity event campaign advisor
campaign manager Kellyanne Conway a
woman who will be praised for breaking
through the glass ceiling if it had
happened under the umbrella of the DNC
or she showed her tits at a March but
because she works with Donald Trump they
had someone doing opposite and
opposition research and they decided to
make this a headline front-page article
at Huffington Post watch Kelly Anne
Conway bombing at trying to do stand-up
years ago for a charity function
emphasized on the trying to do stand-up
roll clip okay at first glance that is
pretty bad but the point is in order to
attack Trump these people who fancy
themselves brave if it sounds like I'm
repeating it because I feel the need to
with every single story keep in mind
they're saying we need to be brave and
just you need to be brave and point out
that that Kellyanne Conway who did some
stand-up for a charity function isn't
good at it this is news I think I agree
with with Van Jones on this what in the
holy hell let's be fair I think we might
have used it out of context I might have
I I don't think I don't think he's too
fond of the Donald Trump well we have to
get going this segment that sorry I hope
I hope I've crystallized the picture for
you but before we leave you know we
actually need to check in Shia LaBeouf's
he will not divide us by the way in case
you even heard he will not divide us his
livestream and we're getting
that actually might be a white
supremacist there let's let's check in
here we're not divided I'm disappointed
a new hopper we had a lot riding it it
doesn't take a lot to buy you off
I'm disappointed where's your loyalty to
God in country sir speaking of God in
country we have Tim Kennedy one of our
wonderful veterans coming up after this
stay tuned dar me
Oh
what are you doing oh you're here okay
get out
eh I was I was actually thinking get out
of my bed we should do some dromio like
likes like commercials like sketches
maybe like you and I go like like they
being good some maybe like two like
side-by-side like like Bert and Ernie
maybe we could do it that way how about
no mattresses and I throw you in the
pool get out of my bed maybe well just
just think about it here
okay now socks let's get back to me what
do you want
I just know that your smiles friend I
come today with you again because a
vision I was dreaming of you and I
together sleeping and the comfort RPO
sleep with brighter calm for specials
and free shipping and a pillow within
the sound of silence
[Music]
having dates to that one in a while
because there's a lot to made track good
friend of the show all over the news
today you know him you love him he
waterboarded me you can find good Tim
son they say that's why they love him MA
some may say we were just talking about
that I read that at on some news article
today it said Tim Kennedy who most
recently waterboarded steven crowder as
part of a christmas telethon makes it
sound so much more worse than actually
was it says it wasn't that bad it wasn't
that bad you were very gentle okay so
let's go through the the sequence of
events here that led to why you're on
the program first off so his Deadspin a
sports website and you can correct me if
I get anything wrong here Ted Cruz said
he was playing basketball on the hill
and so Dead's been asked him to send
proof and he sent this tweet which Tim
can't see but he sent this tweet of a
picture of a basketball player who
looked like Ted Cruz as a gag it was
actually pretty funny this player looks
like Ted Cruz to which Deadspin promptly
responded go eat [ __ ] I want to make
sure some would say they were the
instigator here and then Ted Cruz close
to the anchorman meme that escalated
quickly
okay good thing the guy has a sense of
humor then this reporter on Deadspin
goes out and effectively challenges any
and all Ted Cruz supporters to a fight
and claims that no one will take him up
on it
enter Tim Kennedy have that timeline
about right yeah but he really doubled
down on I mean it wasn't like he just
initially was like hey let's all fight
there was more to it yeah after Ted Cruz
you know sent that picture of that Duke
basketball player which I thought was
funny you meet Jeb man is like oh wow
that's laid it quickly when he started
cussing at us um and then Tim got on
there Marshman and started just ranting
all these ugly things calling people all
these horrible names and saying nasty
things and cussing at people yeah and
then he's like talent agent went on and
on and on I don't know I don't know what
was going on like what bad cop [ __ ] up
coffee yet but yeah it was a might Oh
toxins he needs to get Dave Asprey
coffee my toe toxin
he needs it finally he's like alright
well I'm not getting enough attention so
I'm just gonna call all these people and
tell them that I will fight them right
and then after he did that he doubled
down and it was like not only are all
these people not gonna fight me but they
probably can't even do a push-up right
yeah and enter Tim Kennedy which he was
to which you responded I am your
huckleberry for those who don't
understand the tombstone reference well
played Tim let it never be said that you
are not a man filled to the brim with
good film references since it so you've
actually you you were serious about this
because you've raised some money Glenn
Beck put some money and it's been
matched right so how much money is at
play right now and have you heard a
response yeah so Glenn Beck's said hid
donate fifty thousand dollars to the
charity I'm the winner and I said I can
guess where that's going
not like celebrity are you winning your
task making paper mache diapers in a
fistfight I I know where I'd place my
bets yeah and I said I would max it with
my personal money that the winner of the
fight would get a fifty fifty thousand
dollar donation from me animala G
reference from tombstone actually goes
all the way back to medieval times where
the the Knights once a woman had been
kind of accosted or offended a guy would
write up to her and she would place a
piece of huckleberry garland on his
lamps or his sword and effectively
saying I'm your hero I'm here to back
you up
you're whoever offended you I'm gonna
fight against you so it was appropriate
for the scenario but new renaissance i
want to hear about you punching people i
don't want to hear about your
intellectual contributions he's not
gonna fight no no no so he's the
embodiment he is the personification of
everything that is wrong with this
current impotent culture yeah this
culture where I'm gonna yell I'm gonna
bark I'm gonna say all this tough-guy
stuff but I'm gonna no I'm not gonna
back it up with anything right right I'm
gonna be tough when there's 500 of us
that we're smashing a window at a
Starbucks right
but when it really comes down to the
rubber meeting the road yeah there's not
a man to be found no on that side of the
argument
no any well well I wouldn't say I'm that
I would say certainly people like this a
Deadspin let's be honest the flat whites
are really timid I've yes
careful Tim Kennedy also a coffee snob
in case you didn't know there is an
Austin you wouldn't expect it from him
also he makes pottery with Patrick
Swayze behind the ghost don't don't lie
don't lie I saw you on ghost hunters so
here is here's something I people say oh
you're a hypocrite because I challenge
the guy who sucker punch me at that
Union rally to a fight it's not the same
thing a guy sucker punched me and I said
ok same thing charity of your choosing a
sanctioned MMA bout knows very careful
to phrase it that way basically of
course you get the bet you do someone
could sucker punch you and it could be
lights out you know it wasn't lights out
but I would never call out an entire
ideology of people for example even
liberals because you know what I know if
I say no liberal can fight I could get a
phone call from Jeff Monson and I'm in
trouble
yeah Jeff Monson stuff yeah Jeff Monson
is a big dude also walking human pin
cushion case you didn't know so I was
aware yeah so what kind of I mean I was
gonna do research on this guy people
will want it does he have some
background like does he have an ace up
his sleeve does he train no maybe I know
to all questions no he doesn't do
anything no he's never done anything he
might wear a flannel shirt and walk
around like a tough guy yeah
when did the flannel shirt the mark of
the tough guy know because I wasn't
aware of that
yeah like the Millenial thing like you
you you walk down and these hipsters
with their mustaches and their flannel
shirts and their tight jeans drinking
you know an $8 pour over a cup of coffee
bring it back - yeah - Jared's flat
white but they act like tough guys but
they don't like mines will carry an axe
well you know what I was trying to tree
down for a fanny pack
I don't perceive it that way I always
perceive them kind of doing the
on the runway it's called lumberjack fat
book so I think they coined the term
lumbersexual I guess I am guilty of
today yeah well he have the Newsboys cap
so it sort of takes it away from this
kind of kind of weird juxtaposition no
wasn't there someone else though who did
say he would he would fight this guy
who's not a professional fighter and
asked you if he would be in his corner
so there's been several people who
stepped up to the plate right yeah I
think the most notable is Joey Jones
who's a double amputee listen you're
being a jerk owl straight up hop in
there and fight Joey Jones is a hero and
I would put my money on Joey Jones and I
would unquestionably step in that guy's
corner yeah yeah and then there's
another guy that was just some random
dude that's like listen I'm not a
professional fighter I'm not a green
beret
I'm not Special Forces sniper I'm not a
ranger I'm not 220 pounds of muscle but
I'll get in there I'll give it my best
world I think people are forgetting that
because look so long we the kind of
conservatives yeah we've been turning
our cheeks now we have been kind we have
been generous and people have mistaken
that kindness for weakness
yeah listen we're talking about the
largest group of Second Amendment lovers
we're talking about the guys that really
do hard work to have calloused hands but
are wearing frickin body armor that's
sitting in a rental call are talking to
you on the phone these are the people
that you're insulting so listen we've
been kind for too long I'm sick of
turning my teak if these internet tough
guys keep talking smack through my
friends or anything about kind of yes I
would love to have a rational logical
conversation but I'm not gonna do is sit
there and take it anymore
yeah and that was a great speech until
people realize that your your rental car
is a hybrid
[Laughter]
it is I don't know that's pretty common
Blake agrees inside and his balls shrank
three sizes that day somebody walking a
hybrid you're like I'm Steven Seagal my
nipples are lactating what mistake are
making this for weakness I didn't
realize that that guy was an amputee you
challenged him I did see one time that
quadriplegic who fought Emma made you
know I'm talking he just kind of novels
like to his opponent that's his name I
don't remember but he was actually okay
yeah well he was because you can't kick
it down Department so the guy will just
go on up there I wrote the guy looking
at him looking at the ref and just kind
of know what to do didn't know him you
know either way it's like fighting a
girl there's no winning it's like I beat
the quadriplegic well you're a jerk or
you lost to a quadriplegic there's no
good way to handle maybe that's what the
dead spitting guy isn't answering so
he's going to complete radio silence has
he email view in private like hey listen
man you know I'm sorry I went too far or
is it a total tuck tail and run for now
are you right now I'm in the middle of
nowhere at a shooting range bedrooms you
know my email has been retweeted like
40,000 times yes
so I keep getting all of these awesome
emails from fellow barrel-chested
freedom fighters yeah we'll just call
them that listen I got your back
whatever happens I got your back that's
like sweet dude I love it so I can't get
to any of those emails right now because
I have maybe 500 emails that have come
in the past 24 hours
yeah well that's that's incredible but
do you feel that with your statement
just now about barrel-chested that
you've it all marginalized the suitcase
chested that's think that's a common
argument in the masculine community you
are a barrel-chested though you're like
a fireplug you're pretty compact guy
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna be a lot bigger
the next time you see me oh right right
after my fight that's true back to like
220 I'm gonna be like 240 by the end of
summer but why do you why do you why do
you want to do that you want to be cut
the kid in a hook where you can just
fold up your legs and roll down the ship
like a cannon
I mean just in case a Jeff Monson picks
up one of my tweets I gotta be ready to
go you know what I'm saying yeah well
you know Jeff Monson is an interesting
character now we get off into the weeds
but people who don't know he was I think
he was arrested for spray-painting on
either Capitol step something he's an
anarchist but then he calls himself an
anarchist a narco socialist or a narco
communist and and people acted like I
was stupid I was going on those those
two can't really be the same thing
though they contradict each other okay
so it's not just me then Jeff Monson's
slightly [ __ ] even though he could
beat me up yeah but both of those
concepts are completely on the opposite
end and cannot coexist all right so
let's assume that this guy does not pick
up the the red telephone to fight you
what's yeah what's next then for Tim
Kennedy well in this little feud I guess
we just all acknowledge that all of
these people that keep getting online
and are tough guys in front of a
computer let me remind you that there's
people like me that like to read those
things and aren't gonna take your [ __ ]
yeah what if um what if he he shows up
like to your gym but but he's got body
armor on and he has like he has friends
and and and I like this your gym would
probably have a lot of your friends as
well I don't think I need my friends for
his friends his friends would the only
thing I would hear is the door locking
behind them yes yeah House of Pain
starts yes exactly well hopefully have a
DJ at your gym along with a videographer
my dad always use that to remember that
Jordan dad would always say hey put him
in a racquetball court lock the door
behind him see who comes out yeah it has
before the Octagon exam a big mouth a
racquetball court okay but outside of
that Tim where can i dopey-looking find
you on twitter but what about these
courses and stuff that you have going on
let people
I can find you I want to like walk
around the corner so you could see
what's going on right now I'll just open
the window okay let's see what this is
people well right now we're just seeing
the awful hybrid I'm in body armor
sounds so childish for a fighter so you
can come to any Steve you need to come
to one of my sheep dog horses and go
shooting with us I would love that we
should send not gay Jerry to that he's
actually he's actually probably shoots
more often than I do but would still
probably cower like a small girl I'm
sure he'd be fine so alright so I you're
not wearing their protective ear gear
Tim okay so tell me we have to go to the
sheepdog course what is it for people
who are interested so right now this is
all law enforcement here okay loud yeah
I know that's against the gun part of it
so it's essentially it's a few days of
fighting learning how to be the hardest
person somebody ever tries to kill so we
go over hand hand combat defensive
tactics self-defense and then we go into
shooting night fighting it's taught by
the highest most experienced Special
Forces Navy SEAL badasses on the planet
yeah so it's like a silent retreat
except you learn how to kick ass yes
alright Tim Kennedy at tim kennedy MMA
thank you so much for being with us and
listen you will have to have you come
back and update us if if this guy takes
you up on the offer all right thank you
good sir that was Tim Kennedy and we'll
be back after this I think we have an
McElhinney
coming on up oh she's Irish
[Music]
d'armée and restless sleep I toss along
on this little mattress made of stone
[Music]
would prefer to sleep on da me oh
nothing really wants with doggy oh but
it's the best lead chefs had make room
for me I'm adore me Oh
Darby Oh sleep with rider dot-com for
specials and free shipping and a pillow
all right Jared meet them Mike of our
guest here ah glad back I can't believe
she's got some nerve how many times do
you hear me do live Reed's once a week
that's when you hear me do live Reed's
and of course we're talking about the
mug club this week thanks so much for
everyone who signed up if waterboarding
wasn't enough we went undercover to the
women's March dressed as women so we
were publicly humiliated for you and
offer you you get daily credit right neg
at the free live stream that doesn't
change we've always said this all the
free stuff is still free Thursday daily
articles daily videos absolutely but if
you want the daily show at CR tv.com
ninety-nine dollars annually 69 dollars
for students military or veterans active
military or veteran you shouldn't be an
active veteran relax at that point take
it easy and you know what not only does
it give you access to this hand a shmup
which is high-quality but allows us to
fight back against left and it keeps
people employed we've got Jared we've
got Jordan we've got Edward we've got
Aaron we've got Brautigan Courtney Casey
Francine Lacey Scott and all of them are
employed by your dollar supporting it
keeping us out of the social media well
we're still on the social media ghettos
Facebook Twitter YouTube but we can't be
dependent on them because they can
decide to try and shut that valve off
anytime so uh listen if you can't afford
it it's about 585 a month
we'll still give you all the free stuff
that you get if you can't afford it we
appreciate it in doubt we're really
putting out some good content for you
there
CR tv.com a lot of credit um slash mug
Club everyday oh gosh it's just I have
to sip that I don't know you know that's
the beverage quality is improved it's
actually better 42 percent my doctor
told my gynecologist told me so let's go
on like this is going well
[Music]
[Music]
and all the Federation
[Music]
all right we need to work on our audio
hand signals we are going to your live
tweets before we bring on our next guest
Jordin what are the results from the
poll earlier the poll do you want want
me to read the question UN yes let's
read the question and give us the
results shades as Donald Trump brought
us closer to doomsday rooting the
results late on okay later on that
should say oh I misspelled it gosh oh
thanks thanks for thanks for being a
brother there honestly hadn't read it
into your pants till you were four
continue eight percent said yes 40
percent said no okay 34% said CBS sucks
and 18 percent said we're all gonna die
yeah well thank you for the I appreciate
that you put more enthusiasm into that
than actually assisting your brother and
covering up your question we have to
stop skewing those polls seems like
those additional options could be
skewing those polls some great tweets
some great images but you can bring this
up Michael Ian Black decided to tweet me
boy wrong yeah couple million followers
it seems like he's gone off the deep end
what is he is he a UCB guy um I think so
I don't know which he's one of those
actually his stuff is actually very
funny I've always thought so a lot of
the stuff I've watched him in he has
been funny but he's got a little off the
deep end on Twitter of this election
season odd is he took an old video from
nine from like nine months ago no this
was years ago the Lena Dunham rape
culture Jared yeah yeah and all he
tweeted back sorry this is a very
leftist thing is holy [ __ ] period
yeah nothing else as that's an argument
so I offered him to come on to the show
to discuss air his grievances and he
responded me like 19 times and it's
remarkable how a guy for two million
followers gets no retweets or likes it
really is weird says I appreciate the
offer but would feel slightly ridiculous
debating rape culture with another dude
there are many victims would be far
better to speak then myself in fact
probably every single adult woman I know
could share with you so I offered him to
speak with one of our head writers
Michael Ian Black
Courtney scoffs Courtney kerchief or
Casey and of course he declined
what else do you read here again I would
encourage them to speak with victims of
sexual abuse because I'm not one I don't
feel qualified to speak on their behalf
but I believe their stories I've heard
so many so listen Michael Ian Black
close-minded drunken stupid is no way to
go through life son you want to come on
here and just tweet out some blanket
holy [ __ ] so this is what we've talked
about with the left right where you say
hey rape cultures not true yeah so
instead of saying well no I believe it's
true here's some statistics right the
left goes oh holy [ __ ] can you believe
this guy yeah yeah we can
hey Islam tends to create more more
violent cultures than Christianity the
modern world can you believe it yes yes
the women's March was by large a farce
with all the [ __ ] hats and Ashley
mm-hmm
this is what percent an argument you've
been invited onto the show you try to
take a parting shot in Michael Ian Black
you've got more Twitter followers than I
do you have the support of Viacom Comedy
Central these networks you've been in
some films I know right we're just some
kids with a podcast you know it started
out in the den so listen man prove me
wrong prove one of my writers wrong and
by the way how do you not know that
Courtney or Casey or maybe one of our
wives or sisters or mothers experienced
sexual assault so but again none of that
would matter Michael if you that's this
testicular fortitude just to show up
just to enter the arena brother just
show up swing the bat once I don't even
care if it's a foul ball we don't care
just show up just don't take parting
shots like a coward and I think that
once you start doing that you'll you'll
regain the respect of your following um
I think they don't seem overly eager to
tweet you there's too many sports
reference though for a guy like Mike Lee
he's probably more of a jock than I am I
just I always find it remarkable what do
you say your I don't that was my point I
can't speak from personal experience and
I don't want to speak on anyone's behalf
well you spoke on behalf of the offended
social justice warriors Michael Ian
Black that's why you left that that
comment so listen I think you're funny I
think you're talented guy I think you're
bright enough that we could have a
discussion it could be productive but
these ideas can never actually be
discussed
if you
show up and hey isn't it great Michael
Ian Black
that you live in a town and work in an
industry where no one expects you to
that's the miracle of soft expectations
they expect you to be a better self
little [ __ ] and you continue to be and
by God you are right on par with exactly
what they want from you all right we
have a guest to come up who seems eager
she's chomping at the bit I always love
her because she comes out of her voice
can make any day a happy day I think for
her she's celebrating before she comes
on after give her plug Gosnell book.com
you know they did Gosnell movie before
she talked about that Dean Cain wasn't
it and I know they ran into some hiccups
speaking of the entertainment industry
they're not super keen on the abortion
films Gosnell book calm and McIlhenny
you said you were celebrating today you
went to the White House Phyllis in oh
it's great to see you Steven
I I just wanted I just want to do I have
I I can't not mention the fact that
Stephanie he's a new favorite first-time
Stephanie needs her own show I think we
need a reality show with Stephanie I
want to know everything about Stephanie
I once I want to be I want to be Watson
Stephanie you know just like we don't
mean Sammy afternoons with Stephanie
evenings with Stephanie I'm just gonna
put that right
all the times of day with Stephanie
press that take that we can do an answer
to the view you and Stephanie could sit
on a roundtable drink too much coffee
and safes to I think this is a whole
future for us Steve I think we have
something to talk about here and I know
that you're the agent for Stephanie so
if you could talk to her whatever yet
I'll have her people yes I am
celebrating I'm celebrating I in fact
even have brought a glass of wine to you
that I'm celebrating because you know a
lot of people are tweeting and saying
that they're tired of winning
I'm not tired of winning I'm just liking
winning book was published
yeah gone look on Tuesday on Tuesday and
on Tuesday the book went to number three
in the bestsellers on Amazon not in any
category in the all the categories
awesome and it slipped a little bit this
week and it went back to number three
today I was on the Rush Limbaugh Show
today I was on a Riley on Tuesday but
here's the thing that happened then that
peeled all of that into insignificance
in a way and just made everything just
kind of crazy and amazing and
providential mm-hmm I got an invitation
to the White House today from Trump
Ramon from Israel just I have just come
back from the White House where I have
met vice president vice president Penn's
beautiful wife and I have met Kellyanne
Conway who is you know let's talk about
women let's get into this whole women
thing I know you know let's celebrate
women well you missed her aren't we were
talking about this earlier where people
they talk about how it's our time to
stand up to Donald Trump as journalists
and HuffPo trotted out some old it was
like a charity thing or Kellyanne Conway
in the early 90s was doing stand-up
which granted was was really bad but
she's not a stand-up comedian it was for
charity and to me it's gotten to the
point where they want to pat themselves
on the back for being brave journalists
but they will go after people who have
at any point worked for Trump for the
most trivial kind of crap and of course
if any of anyone on the right that it
would be considered a wildly sexist but
Mike Pence I imagine that he would have
a firm handshake Mike pen
so we're with the we're in the room it's
you know first of all we go through the
whole security thing and you know we're
I you know I am I think it'll take me a
while to get over the fact of what just
happened to me you know yeah I bring in
an immigrant I'm one of those immigrants
I'm wills legal immigrants so grateful
to be here and every time I renew my
visa I can tell you I don't mind the
hassle because I'm grateful that I'm
allowed to be here I haven't done the
green card because it's it's very
laborious and I'm really really busy but
I am not worried about spending money
and spending time on getting a visa
because I'm really grateful to be here
yeah and we go to that I was in the
White House today I was there I met
President I met his wife I met Kelly
Anne and I'm like I'm here so really I
mean amazing I meet Kelly Anne family I
need Kelly Anna fela awareness
like you know your your listeners know
this it's like my god I'm starting from
the kill again and I'm like we're
telling him I'm feeling said feeling
kind of got all kind of mumbly mumbly
and kind of you might feel laughter
which we were meeting a rock star right
and so Salem says you know were the
people who did you know we're doing the
the Gosnell film and she went I know
exactly who you are
I don't exactly who you are and by the
way Gosnell isn't everything that you
did you did frack nation you did all
these other films and we're like going
I'm on your database I get your letters
I'm going oh my god I hope you didn't
react this way it's it's it's less than
professional for it's unbecoming of a
professional filmmaker I was good I was
good Stephen okay but maybe I was maybe
I was a little awestruck and I was and
when I met the vice president's I mean I
met the vice president listen to be
hearing I'm saying those words yeah not
even kind of you know I mean owning them
if you were saying this for years ago it
would have been I was fondled by the
vice president missing around the vice
president I meant the wonderful vice
president's wife who are so yeah there
are people and I know you know we're
having some fun and we want to have a
lot of fun here but they are people of
faith and he spoke I I it was I I felt
part of history tonight but he spoke
about what he why he was there and why
this was important and he was there with
his wife who had dedicated themselves
and tomorrow is a march for life and
they had dedicated themselves so so so
many years ago that their mission in
life was for life and he quoted the
Bible he he talked about prayer he
talked about the importance of prayer
yeah that day well you know
you you yes yes you were there in this
room tonight with him and thought now
now this is what greatness looks like
this is what this looks like yeah
these were these are people of grace and
people providential people yeah and just
we're just we're really lucky and I'm
I'm celebrating I'm having a glass he's
got one hell of a jawline but okay and
we don't have too much time so I do want
to get to this they invited you because
of the Gosnell book now what's
interesting to me - what's the film
before the book you know I've known you
and filum for well I guess that since
Android reduced so 2009 ish right and
you were not pro-life activist at all
you looked into us because you were
journalists real journalists we had a
tackle we had a seafood tackle together
in where Manhattan Beach right beach at
Wahoo's yes yeah and I remember you were
saying we're gonna move to Los Angeles
and film said in Los Angeles I said okay
Phil I'm gonna go with her I'm gonna
listen to her then here in Manhattan
Beach it's so it's so beautiful and I
said I know but there are plenty of nice
places I know the tacos are good I
remembered my god you've got a great
memory I've had too many glasses of wine
to remember us meeting I remember it
really well I remember liking you from
the get-go and and I loved the
relationship we have and here's the
thing about the book and here's the
thing about people buying the book and
I'm gonna show it and it kind of fully
hold on wait a second let me just
preface for people who don't know we
can't get through everything cuz we've
talked about this go back through our
archives those guns now it was a
horrific serial killing abortionist is
the only way I can describe it to
actually understand the horror that is
abortion and certainly how it ties into
the modern regressive left you really
need to look into the stories of Gosnell
and until them have written about it in
and I have yet to read the book I should
be getting it this week I'm really
looking forward to it so that sets the
stage because a lot of people don't know
yet and that's the reason for this book
yeah and the book the book I mean we're
getting some lot of very very good
feedback it's the number three
bestseller in the United States of
America right now right and on Amazon
and it's it's you know there's three
things the three things the book does
and the book tells the personal stories
of these children yeah of
children who died and particularly baby
boy who shares the birthday of my own
father
the 12th of July 2008 and 2008 obviously
um but 12th of July is my father's
birthday and today this is a child who
lived and died on the same day but his
life mattered and his life is
significant mhm and his life will matter
a great deal more the more people read
the story and the more people watch the
movie the more this story gets out he's
the center of the movie he is the center
of the movie baby boy I know who who
lived who Gosnell joked about who ghazal
he's the baby that ghazal said this
baby's big enough to walk me to the bus
stop yeah he's the baby also though that
Adrian Morton took a photograph of and
we write about this in the book
Adrian worked in took a photograph of
baby boy a-and I've interviewed her and
she said that when they came to arrest
her when the cops came to arrest her she
was relieved well said and then she said
to them I'm gonna give you this phone
and she had an old phone and you know
the way you guys keep your listeners and
and and know this stuff and people
watching tonight they know this stuff
that you know you have a phone like an
old phone and then you throw that phone
out and you get a new phone you know
they got a regular order she she kept
the phone she kept that old phone and
when the cops turned up she had the
phone and she said to them you need to
take the phone there's a photograph
there that that's important and she said
um and finally I'm free
that's what she said about baby boy and
the photograph of baby boy people can
look it up online baby boy Gosnell if
you put that in you'll see the
photograph it's not for everyone to
watch that it's not for everyone to see
this right and I I speak to pro-life
audiences across the country and I
always now you know I've learned I used
to be a pro-choice you know I was that
person right not that long ago and so
now I go to these groups who asked me to
speak and I will say for them I'm not
going to show you any photographs and
people applaud people applaud me when I
say that and so I'm very conscious of
people not wanting to see photographs
and I'm not gonna be forcing people to
see photographs but
baby boy any mattered and at the end of
the book we have a whole section about
the forty-seven bodies of the babies
that were found on the premises have
been buried now and and a lot of
Christian folk and good folk came along
and I'm not not just a Christian folk I
would say just good folk maybe not
necessarily religious came along and
wanted those children get buried and
have people memorialize them and people
know them and and do and do something to
to to remember that that they were
remembered that they are remembered and
there are at the end of the book we have
a load of quotations from the people who
went to that memorial service and there
will be a permanent memorial there and
I'm really happy about that I hope that
memorial is made before they make a
memorial to Michael Brown which they say
they're gonna do
and the people who went there spoke
really beautifully and those words were
in the back of the book and and they
said you were not forgotten no you were
not one you were not unwanted we wanted
you and we came for you with love and
your lives matter and I would challenge
anyone to have a dry eye reading the
actual words of the people who spoke at
that beautiful ceremony that happened
and I think this is an amazing book and
I actually encourage people to bias and
I think I say to people you know people
think a lot of people listening tonight
probably Stephen are thinking since us I
can't read that I can't read that you
know what you can and you know what it's
a it's a it's a it's a privilege to be a
witness to life and it's a privilege to
be a witness to everything I'm
privileged to be a journalist who got to
tell this story I'm not sorry for myself
people have written beautiful things to
me and said we're praying for you we
know you're suffering and I have
suffered I have I've cried Oh Sean I
never prayed for many many years until I
read the testimony of Steven Steve
myself which is in the book and it made
me kneel down beside the computer so I
came back to prayer true this well
that's an incredible you know that his
testimony actually is what created you
know yours that's a no lievable story to
tell and it is it's um
I will say this this is we were taught
we don't have too much time and I'll
give you the last word but I think a
line in the sand we were talking about
this when we were at the Women's March
and we were there and it was really just
a scene of just depravity and I was
going these people the dance savages of
the world the Michael Ian Black said the
world they went out there and they
mocked Rick Santorum and his family they
had a stillborn and they brought it home
long ago and they know that story of
course so they brought up to their
family and they they brought it say hey
listen this is your this is your baby I
don't know it was a brother or sister I
don't want to get that wrong Lisa's your
baby brother this is your baby sister
they wanted their kids to understand it
was life and they buried it and the left
said hey isn't that weird while they're
taking bong hits showing their tits
wearing a [ __ ] hat at the Women's March
and I'm going hold on a second to people
who want men to go into women's rooms
they say that it's considered hate
speech for a vagina to be a requirement
to be a woman all this stuff that was
being spoken about at the women's March
and to them the weird thing is somebody
having a stillborn child and considering
it a life and if that doesn't show you
the difference between good and evil
today if that doesn't show you between
who really is that the political party
of depravity and and hopelessness and a
party of life I'm not talking about just
politicization in the news but life
versus darkness I really do think
there's a line in the sand there and
that's not that's as close as I get to
on my soapbox I hope people read their
look Gosnell book docum
go ahead and I would and I gave a book
to vice president pence this evening and
I wrote on us and I if you've got just
the second for me to tell you that I
wrote I wrote in the dedication to the
vice president I said to vice president
pence silence in the face of evil is is
evil not to act not to speak is to speak
not to act is to act thank you for
speaking thank you for acting you are an
inspiration sir and I and we signed us
and I and I and I do think you I mean I
cannot tell you how significant it was
to me to be in that room with him for
him to be so warm and kind to us Kelly
and to recognize the book and to
recognize what we're trying to do here
this story is shocking the story I mean
you know I mean we could talk forever
Steven and you know that and I know
you're trying to wrap up but you know
your law the law in the United States of
America the only place really that has
the laws like you have is North Korea
and if you want to be like North Korea
you know that's that's not the America I
think an awful lot of people want to
live in and I even mean progressives if
they want to be compared to North Korea
but you could have an abortion at nine
months you know that's the law here
that's the law here and that's the
strength of this book because it reminds
people of what this is really about
these children
yeah and it's important to realize to
take that face to think of it and then
think of Wendy Davis and Debbie
wasserman-schultz
and those people who it went from safe
legal and rare which I still would say
morally is an argument still wrong to
abortion taxpayer-funded on-demand no
questions asked
period and people need to understand
that's the main platform of the
Democratic Party right now that's not
some social justice fringe that is wendy
davis to roaring applause anyone out
there read it read the book Gosnell book
calm and then read the platform of the
wendy davis of the world please do and
then listen you can come to us tweet me
tweet and McIlhenny and and let him know
your opinions and McIlhenny Gosnell book
calm thank you so much go back to the
wine be a happy drunk love where the
look we love you so much Steven if it's
not it's obscene well thank you so we
love you everyone we all talk about how
much we love you here too but we have to
slam dunk e here and McIlhenny thank you
so much for being here
and hang up on it are you gonna make it
awkward now if you don't hang up on her
because that makes me seem meaner than I
am
thank you so much to Ann McIlhenny and
maybe we'll have philemon one time when
it gets a he gets coached on speaking
American we are going to be back to wrap
this show up at a nice ribbon for you a
final segment last second of the week
they do
[Music]
looks like Timmy's in for a check-up
because he's feeling sluggish Oh Timmy
just as the doctor suspected you have
IEDs informative entertainment
deficiency syndrome the good news is
there's a cure for that ladder with
credit.com slash mug club for only 99
dollars annually 69 for students active
military or veterans you can cure
yourself of the plague that is IEDs
ladder with Carter comm slash Mudd Club
don't be a [ __ ]
[Music]
we legitimately hold our breath for that
entire segment we do there's no reason
to no one would knows we wait that was
the last segment holding my breath every
week speaking about starting next week
it's not the last segment because not
gay Jerrod and Courtney scoffs have a
show starting I don't know what that
looks like so I'm very nervous and we
have a bunch of guests next week we have
uh what's the name Sean gosh
Merriman yep Shawn Marion I believe Bo
Derek I don't know I believe a whole
bunch and we have something I will tell
you this we have to be careful we may
have a shorter show next Wednesday
because we'll be reporting on location
on Thursday in a way that we've never
done before it's a big risk but if we do
I think you'll want to tune in and it's
not a it's not a fake tease you know if
we if we say someone like this it means
that we are actually we're all going on
the road we will be putting in quite a
bit of effort so next week could be a
little bit of a screwy schedule we
appreciate you working with us we are
not taking time off we will be all root
thank you so much to Tim Kennedy and
McIlhenny and here's something that I do
think is an important takeaway we were
talking about this this week all
throughout the week it's actually kind
of amazing I've always tried to be
relatively fair I'm biased but my rules
are be open about my biases be open
about where my point of view lines up
and more importantly never attack
someone without offering them recourse
never attacks want to take a parting
shot so I I'm not saying that I'm I'm
bipartisan or a journalist I'm not okay
please understand that and please don't
use me as your main news source I never
want to be like Jon Stewart I want you
reading from everywhere and in fact I
prefer you reading from the leftist
sources half the stories we've run come
from salon and our daily costs or
Huffington Post because I think it's
important to be informed the other side
so that being said I like to think that
we're relatively fair on this show even
though we're biased um and I've always
good to say I think there are people who
are obviously and I still believe this
who are wrong on the Left would aren't
bad people but I will say this isn't
necessarily emblematic of the left as a
whole or people who pull the lever for
Democrats as a whole but the regressive
left as dave rubin puts it the modern
democratic party and they're complicit
media we have reached the point and I
won't again I'm not throwing all
liberals in this category but
have reached a point where the media and
the DNC are borderline compulsive liars
if you see it this week um and you know
that you see when somebody continually
repeats something
they vehemently repeat it it's almost
always a lie
and that's how you know when they
continue lease feminists are the
majority we talked about that right
feminists of the majority feminism not
even close
women are the majority of United States
of America and feminists make up about a
fifth of women so take half the country
take a fifth of that the math is about a
tenth this was everywhere the media
reported it because they try and draw
this correlation well the March was the
biggest March in modern American history
that's about 2.5 million people out of a
country of three hundred three and fifty
million people out of 164 million women
therefore since this is the biggest
March feminists are the majority most
women can't stand them it's not the
biggest March it's not even the biggest
civil rights movement it's certainly not
the most effective political movement
remember they try to do that with the
Occupy Wall Streeters and this is a real
first grassroots movement what about the
tea party now look at what happened the
tea party they pry married incumbents
they brought in new politicians they
took over the House and Senate where's
Occupy Wall Street there might be one
guy still dropping deuces in zanotti
Park that's about it they're nowhere to
be found it's gonna be the same with the
vagina hats you hear this week we need
to be brave when you stand up you know
what reports it's time we start standing
up to Donald Trump people are afraid hey
respect to my fellow journalists who are
brave you are brave you are brave I am
brave you are brave they're all cowards
it's a consistent lie they pat
themselves on the back because they know
that if they position themselves as as
the party of opposition as the underdog
which they're not here's what's
important to note this is not the same
kind of presidency as Barack Obama and
we were worried about this somewhat
because you know a lot of historically
Republicans conservatives have gotten
complacent under Republican president we
said well you know it's a with this
election when it looked like Hillary was
was going to win or it looked you know
like there was a decent chance we said
well at least you know what we'll be
fighting against Hillary and we know
that that we can be the voice of
opposition we can help with that and we
thought that if Donald Trump won people
would kind of take some time off which
tends to happen a lot but that's not the
and you know why it's so remarkable this
is a big difference being Barack Obama
was the man he was the establishment
there's no doubt about that
but Donald Trump still isn't you know
why Barack Obama had the media in his
back pocket Barack Obama had the
entertainment industry's back pocket
look at Bruce Springsteen performing the
private banquet for Obama and Bono
sitting there mocking George W Bush when
he was coming in with Barack Obama the
cool kids table who consistently mocked
Donald Trump and tell all of you that
you're stupid and racist for voting for
him it's not the same thing the
establishment is not the guy in the
White House the man so to speak are the
people who control information and right
now for a limited time only that's still
traditional media and the entertainment
industry but that's going away pretty
quickly join the Mudd Club if you want
to support that that's where people like
us are able to equalize that playing
field so it's important to note they are
not the party of opposition and they
know that and so they lie and they say
well we need to be brave and stand up
against Donald Trump you need to be
brave you're the same people who are
mocking his campaign manager for a bad
stand up set in the early 90s gonna be
brave you're mocking his child you need
to be brave you're mocking what he likes
to eat it has been nothing but a doggie
pile on the Trump's they are not brave
this is not some modern civil rights
movement and you don't need to buy it so
if there's anything to take away if
someone continually repeat something and
you see this in the media at any point
immediately question it immediately if
your friends do it if your friend
consistently says you know bro I can
fence you off 400 pounds you know I was
squatting full of 500 pounds for eight
reps you know I think you're lying if
you have to bet your life bet it on them
lying because generally someone who can
actually accomplish what they're
claiming they can't accomplish doesn't
need to claim it so if the media was
really being brave it would be
recognized right if they were the
biggest this were the biggest civil
rights march of all time in a modern
american history it would be recognized
we wouldn't know it a few vagina hats
and a crazy Ashley Judd tirade does not
a modern civil rights movement make so
don't be fooled you don't have to buy it
if you hear them repeating it it's
likely a lie see you next week I love
you mostly
[Music]
you